we send it down to our courtside
reporter who has not been on the air for
some time because you've been busy wait
you know my all-star break is longer
than you I know I pulled up here my
Hyundai Santa Fe that's what I do know
what's up boys long time no speak is
rondae hollis-jefferson it away I say
say where you been honesty's I'm out
here I'm working hard you know I'm
tucked away trying to finish an album
but but I just want to just I want
everybody to just take in the fact that
like Fred vanvleet turks and caicos 10
is just on 10 million and that Cowboys
looking like four out of the league goal
that's why I keep doing this awesome
they put me on TV but that was look like
Fred of ecole well any time you want to
do the salsa dancers let us know and ya
going let's sublets something back in
neck straight I'm only hitting the
Frederico 20/20
[Applause]
going to work I don't wear the you know
lookie you've been working on your game
too I mean let me tell you what you guys
have had some runs out of the past and
Jack and I are ready anytime you guys
eat now well not anybody else to run
with you because you know we can let me
let me just talk let me just announce on
here that you have a verbal contract
that you you said you would announce our
championship games I think that's a big
deal for our league the SPO I'm happy to
be yeah no we got it we got a great
thing going you know it's a it's been a
blessing it's uh Brock brought all my
friends you know I've been friends with
all these guys for like ten plus years
and just brought us closer together man
getting us keeping us active as the as
the years are ticking off the clock boys
you don't want to talk about scrubs on
the air though quavo beware come on how
dare you how about this dunk right here
by the way Drake you know what a little
hello and the best part about it is that
typically tipoff is very late into the
evening which is perfect for Jack that's
my gym in the morning is just perfect
yeah hundred percent honestly it's it's
a
it's a loose League you know we've got
it we've got a red wine cooler I'm on a
strict Reed teeth I here's eight in the
spin move on the inside and a nice move
by the big man in his second year that's
a first I'll come on let's move out in
the second bucket come on now there's
Kyle Lowry on the inside
it's Kyle come down to the path and put
some shots up Kyle Kyle's come to a game
at the Epley Kyle comes to the house and
puts shops up ya know it's it listen
it's a family atmosphere obviously like
this team is family to me these guys are
always always popping in and they're
always welcome to come and train work
out there you know I love it Ricky Rubio
with the shot here it's good stuff a
little quick the Toronto Raptors yes I
mean how about this 40 and 15 best
record through 55 incredible yeah it's
incredible look I'll say this it's it's
always it's always a daunting task when
you when you lose a polarizing player
like like like the one that we you know
a loss after winning the championship
but these guys just have heart man like
I said we're a family and and they're
and they're just they're playing for
something you know it just proves that
it wasn't about one player it was never
about one that one guy didn't win us a
championship you know this team warned
us this championship these guys their
heart their fight and just the fact that
they're they're all guys that are nice
to each other showing love to each other
and trust me in these unwelcoming times
you know there's been a lot of a lot of
things going on in the world right now
and it's always just a positive vibe to
be around these guys when when you
you know you'd be at dinner in the
locker room but man they're just a great
group of guys and and and their karma
shines through you know it's just it's
it's their Carmenere hard works they're
just they're winners you know with or
without with or without you know whoever
decided to take that take that
that permanent flight that beautifully
because that's the essence right when
you look at any good team in Fross war
just that's the essence of a good team
yeah hundred percent I mean the things
you talked about that's chemistry 100
percent in and like you know it's like
obviously I talk basketball all the time
so you'll hear you know you'll hear you
know the s unpopular popular opinion
whatever it is that you know I mean it
takes a starter to win but you realize
now watching this team that you know
it's it's often it's often just as much
about the supporting cast and by the way
none of these guys are supporting casts
I mean we've got superstars you know we
have two all-stars and so yeah man it's
great you know I mean it's a it's
incredible to watch and that's my god by
the way I can't see the td3 show in
there but ya know it's it's amazing I
just can't wait to see them in the
playoffs I don't think anything's gonna
change I think we're gonna come with the
same energy and and yeah you know well
I'm just excited for everybody else in
the Eastern Conference that comes in
this building and gets shook I hope all
you boys are at home watching this
knowing when you come this building you
got some limits
Oh Terrence Davis again the cd3 show hey
this is a building [ __ ] right outside
of Memphis come on spell Mississippi
right now Matt what do you come on it's
the Mississauga - gosh yeah
can I get one more orange juice please
we meet we we need some vitamin C for
dream FF here's Laur look at this boy
someone put the camera on this guy's
Tanner get the camera on that dad oh my
goodness that boys looking rejuvenated
we had 649 to go we got Pascal checking
in we got a highlight for you here
[Applause]
that's what I came to see the td3 show
but ya know I'm looking forward to it
you know you know I think I think we're
gonna have an incredible playoff run we
obviously always have fun of the
playoffs and and yeah you know what like
I said man these boys coming this
building it's a different story you know
I'm saying they get on that foul line
they get a little [ __ ] boy and jeans
with a clock down I have some of this
orange juice you talking about it's good
for you this vitamin C huh yeah it is
what games are coming up does anyone
know well home games do we have yeah
that's you know I'll be here for that
giannis oh yeah and then Charlotte by
the way this is the longest home
sandwiches leave only four games and
then the Raptors head out for March your
guy Mike Budenholzer will be here
Tuesday and I were the Bucs I love it
that's what I can't wait to see to
friends and family